Okay, so, so we can serve more requests concurrently. That's
true. So, one of the limiting factors of a website is.
How many requests a machine can handle at once? You know,
each, each time a, a user connects to your machine that
uses what's called a connection. The connections take memory. They
take CPU to, to deal with. And of course, you know,
the CPU to handle the requests. So, you know, we want to
scale so we can handle more requests concurrently. Alright, how about
storing more data? Yep, that can be a reason to
scale. Sometimes just storing so much data that it won't fit
on one machine, or in one, you know, one database.
Or it won't fit in memory, or you need more disk
space. You know, there's all sorts of reasons that data
might be a limiting factor, memory, disk speed. And that's another
reason to scale. So we're more resilient to failure. Yes,
absolutely. You know, sometimes you add multiple machines into your system,
you know, you have multiple databases, we talked about that in
unit three. We talked about replication. You know re, replication is
important for databases. So that if, if one of those machine
dies or goes off flying. You don't lose any data and
your website still works. Same with your application servers where, where
your programs are running. Sometimes those break or, you know, go
offline or become disconnected or for whatever reason aren't accessible. And
so you have multiple ones, so you're resistant to failure. And,
finally, to serve more requests faster. Yes, this
is also an answer. It's similar to serving more
requests concurrently. Which requires, you know, being, the
ability to handle multiple connections or many connections. Serving
requests faster, may require a bigger machine or
some caching. There's lots of techniques for doing this.
And that falls under the umbrella of, of scaling.
So, these are all good reasons to scale. And,
and they're, they're handful more. But these are the types
of things we're going to be talking about in this lecture.